bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti in
questo nuovo video sono fa vj per chi
sia il sun siren rex maria è basato su
un sottomarino tedesco abbiamo tratto
dell'informazione è un oro al francese
questo parte male scherza ma niente io
sono in esplorazione in questo
sottomarino distrutto tedesco perché
immagino che ci siano tutti ritrovamenti
l'oro della guerra tutto provato che
tutto sotto sotto il mare al recupero
noi non lo so è stato ipotizzato è un
super nautica ancora più più horror cose
che sono sotto madonna ma e non è usato
maria è una nave o sottomarino si capiva
da quanto grosso quantomeno sottoposto
quanto ho fatto bene sto gioco tra
l'altro torreggiare off del rex maria
saranno un sacco depeche dove vado c'è
nel senso devo devo devo andare avanti
nonostante la porta sia blindata che non
l'ho neanche vista sta porta dove questa
e come faccio la leva 1 e calcio
un'altra porta qua non avevo vista la
zia
ok
xj sindrome no vabbè ma che quanto fatto
bene bellissima sta roba si gira tutto
bene messo sono quello delle pulizie che
mi hanno detto che non la facevano le
facciamo come questo si somma che
scrissi che ho scritto fele un flare e
su un flash back e flash
player della curva ok lo sgomento play
alle forze le mettiamo in testa una
chiave tech
ma cos'è che dice qual 98 per cento
ancora ancora
io dovrei
sulla sirena l'ho vista era una sirena
quella quindi ok lo vivo visto la coda
con l'ombra
sulla sirena dentro sta roba ok
infatti il gioco si chiama siren rex
maria sirena e rex maria la nave e
fantasia ci hanno avuto i francesi sto
gioco pro bello
porca [ __ ] aiuto
sto morendo va bene e tanto succede
spesso ci lascio proprio la scia di
sangue per l'acqua e poi basta smetto di
sanguinare così va bene
enter the cloud ma io penso al codice
dovrebbe essere lontano va bene sarà
dietro il quadro
incredibile 40 non è pazzesco c'è un
intuizioni incredibile
4096 cioè ragazzi era quasi giusto o
sbagliato solo una cifra pazzesca
cioè pensate
ok c'è una chiave con dei numeri sopra
questo numero 338
è una una sirena mappa palpato il
chupete tutto normale se non fa niente
grazie di avermi palpato la chiappa
destra ma non è quello che cercava in
questo gioco cercando solo di andare
avanti ci sono meduse per terra ben
presto pendent sa che devo fare da usare
i piedini pop madonna ma quanto fatto
bene
bravo prendi loro finalmente un cacchio
di gioco dove gli oggetti posso portarli
anche dietro e non gli usa una volta
salve credo che ci siano dei problemi
qua però
un
capitan a
mi chiedo me l'aspetto maio port cava
quanto fatto bene quanto fatto bene e
non ho capito la porta che devo aprire
quale dovrebbe essere sto girando a
vuoto
all'inizio eccola qua
1600 chiara madonna quando ci sarà un
tesoro incredibile qua non ci hanno
avuto accesso a bancole silene st porta
incredibile
se non ci trova almeno 25 euro io me ne
vado
vediamo non c'è niente
vabbè stanza insonorizzata voci fi video
posso ancora sentire l'eco del bella
tutti ragazzi incredibile abili che
trasportandolo trasportavano le sirene
era qua dentro che le tenevano poi è
fuggita porca vacca
ecco cosa stiamo trasportando i tedeschi
le sirene a negoi krumm posso uscire di
qua
un flash back les fleurs hughes flare
eva anas esplora ancora più avanti va
bene se tanto tanto guarda
si si non vi sto per niente cagato nelle
mutande non ho ma va sì sì sì sì sì sono
certo che problemi va beh
posso
siliqua
che cosa è una galleria terminati una
cosa un ascensore cos'è
porca vacca mannaggia bye bye bye bye
bye
bye passenger walters
si celle fini 16 gen la bomboletta sta
andando buttandosi scenico è possibile
perché sa dopo dall'ossigeno a perché il
tubo mia core ma dai ma da il tuo mi ha
colpito è affatto un change pensate che
culo che trovata una bombola d'ossigeno
qua pazzesco per terra 38 servivo va
bene beh siamo fatti un km di superficie
adesso che fa
salve ma tutti implicati con dentro o
bene
vorrei andare vorrei chiedere per
cortesia se c'è la possibilità di
parlare con un superiore perché mi
sembra un po bagnata la situazione qua
che servizio è che merda e cos'è questo
c'è ma ci dovrebbe stare a boss fight
gemina
troppo a lombardo posso viaggiare ma no
è un ora siamo tipo in bioshock tramposo
non è spunta il tipo di bioshock big
daddy come sia incredibile quel gioco
ragazzi che ha giocato a bioshock
scrittura nei commenti questo quadro
casa bioshock sì ma dove sono le note
che qui si che è successo il trend va
suoi non tutelo dici a tua madre si sta
riempiendo di scatole
le post si sta riempiendo di scatole
potente
stufi che tutte dov'è che esco di qua
se riempito di sky diventata una boxe i
farisei bella tutti ragazzi noi siamo
siamo al box dove vado
c'è uno col violino ok
c'è stato le sviolinate fatele capi
fatemeh capi
fate mica dove vado o se aperto una
strada va bene sono impaziente come sta
impazzendo e la bombola dell'ossigeno
che mi hanno nome
giorno io chiuderei la porta
dell'ascensore e cambiare il piano se
fossi in te zio
giupres di pesce cougars
marina ris.es sì sì sì ti senti senza 0
e le pudende la signora l venuta piazza
brin e chiude majesco up and deal odilo
faq merda
correte su play.com e texture playing ma
appena preso l'ascensore
ma vabbè ragazzi è bellissimo veramente
un bel gioco complimenti alle france non
ci credo veramente che sia stato fatto
così proprio teatro con joyce il tutto
figo spero riesca il gioco completo è
carino molto carino va bene fatemi
sapere agazzi si è piaciuto siren wall
maria io vi ringrazio verrà visto il
video con ragazzi del video è piaciuta
certo questo è un mi piace anche
prescrizione se ne sono resi schiavi
procediamo ora prossimo video e ragazzi
[Musica]
ma